hi there reject nation I'm Greg halvah
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
looper bloopers that will make you love
the Avengers even more I'm sure this is
gonna be them describing the bloopers
with some footage as opposed to just
watching a great compilation of outtakes
either way looper is one of the best
channels one of my personal favorites so
I'm excited to check this out this is
top warranty request from man named
Mikhail Linden sexy gentleman's spy as I
like to call the bloopers from The
Avengers films might be some of the
funniest we've seen in a while in fact
they're so funny that it's hard not to
fall in love with the films all over
again in the realm of superheroes
especially Norse mythology drive
superheroes you're only as good as your
accessories Thor has quite a few his
long red cape is long blond hair and his
mighty hammer Mjolnir when it comes to
his hammer it's so tough and unbreakable
that it took the might of hella the
goddess of death to finally break it in
Thor Ragnarok maybe they got the idea
for that moment from this blooper man
which Thor's magical hammer sure seems
like a very breakable prop
[Music]
one of the few things as iconic is
Thor's hammer in the MCU is Captain
America shield
it's about as classic as superhero of
equipment gets and it's so powerful that
can't routinely bust through walls and
locks with you unfortunately the real
prop shield they use in the filming is a
lot less useful than its fictional
corpus it's easy for the comic book
version of Bruce Banner to just rattle
off scientific science because someone
can just scribble them into a speech
bubble it's clearly a bit harder for
actors to say all those complicated
words in real life just watch Mark
Ruffalo as he struggles to deliver
what's clearly a mouth full of technical
mumbo-jumbo in the Avengers age of
Ultron in a deleted scene in hired Man 3
Trevor Slattery successfully passes
himself off as a Russian over the pump
which leads the Colonel James Rhodes
asking him to try out a number of other
voices it's really just a chance for
Academy award-winning actor Sir Ben
Kingsley to display his acting ability
and dialect talents because he can
handle every suggestion actor Don
Cheadle throws this way I've come from
Jamaica hey can you do French say can
you do like a Spanish I can do buddy
shut up almost every suggestion British
Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk to
punch a giant alien in the Avengers is a
stand up and clap moment however as it
turns out that wasn't exactly the first
instinct that actor Mark Ruffalo had
when facing down a CGI monstrosity
[Music]
ha
considering how terrifying the aliens
looked on the big screen it's our
default Ruffalo's acting instincts well
Bettany used to just provide the voice
of Jarvis in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but these days he's using his
whole self to play vision Bettany is
fairly recognizable under all that red
makeup while he certainly looks the part
of the super advanced robot he's acting
more like a malfunctioning computer in
this blooper from Captain America Civil
War it's not so more than that another
episode commissioned his maximo
manipulates molecular and fill a cartoon
or one of the most impressive things
about the MCU is that the actors are
able to take it all seriously when
surrounded by goofy costumes and CGI
monsters yeah it's the kind of true
commitment to character that explains
why they get paid so much however that
doesn't mean there aren't a few moments
where that seriousness cuts out in this
lineup of Stern determined looking
heroes for Avengers infinity war
Benedict Wong just couldn't keep the
steely resolve in his face for more than
a few seconds
[Music]
spider-man homecoming included one of
the most memorable cameos in MCU history
when Chris Evans in Captain America pops
in via green screen video to deliver
some corny educational advice to the
students of Peters high school so you
got detention you screwed up however one
particular video is just a bit too
over-the-top or Emmons to make it
through without cracking up hi i'm
captain america whether you're a student
or a soldier there's one thing that will
always give you an edge a city full of
steep hills and this blooper paul rudd
gets into character as he prepares to
shoot one of those sequences an MCU
movie made in the last few years just
wouldn't be complete without a Stan Lee
appearance and ant-man the wasp and one
of the legendary creators best cameos as
Scott Lang hope Van Dyne is their
associates battled bad guys through the
twisty streets of San Francisco Lee
shows up as a guy whose car gets struck
by ant man's signature technology
[Music]
well the 60s were fun but now I'm paying
for it it turns out that's just the take
filmmakers decided on they had Lee go
through a huge list of funny
possibilities oh no my sandwich was in
there well at least now I'll be able to
park in San Francisco
yeah man movies are pretty much the
funniest of all the MCU standalone
flicks the cast of full feature of a
knack for comedy I'm only stating that
against Michael Pena Randall Park and
Judy Greer even so it's a pleasant
surprise for viewers to suddenly
encounter Tim Heidecker a comedy
innovator known for his bizarre
boundary-pushing work on cult TV
favorites like Tim and Eric awesome show
great job in ant-man of the wasp he
plays the leader of a San Francisco Bay
boat to her guy hello find echoes best
lines were unfortunately left for the
blooper reel though free for whales I
love them ever since I was a kid I'm a
trained brilliant in biology or knowing
anything about them
I've memorized a couple of facts but I
couldn't go deep life's answer is a
crowning achievement in filmmaking and
it also gave the world one of the
all-time great movie catchphrases it
even makes an appearance in Avengers
infinity war
since Black Panthers release in early
2018 millions have flashed each other
the crossed arms salute by now everyone
knows how to say what Conda correctly
but during the film's production a few
cast members had trouble getting it down
in this clip neither Martin Freeman nor
Danai gurira are confident in their
ability that thing that was on your arm
dr. strange was a harder sell than your
typical superhero movie after all dr.
Stephen strangest powers come from an
ability to connect with the worlds of
mysticism and magic to effectively
ground that in reality the filmmakers
required the services of an actor with
extensive classical training and an
impressive resume full of award-winning
dramatic roles that actor Benedict
Cumberbatch who earned widespread
acclaim for his work in Sherlock and the
imitation game but who knew that
Cumberbatch could be so silly underneath
all the pomp and circumstance he's just
as goofy on set as a whacky comic actor
judging from this blooper reel he's
especially down to get down
breaking into dance routines while
filming his scenes because most of his
co-stars got in on the dance craze to
panic televisions longest-running hits
is America's Funniest Home Videos
debuting in 1990 this long-running
series has delighted the masses with
miles of poorly shot and grainy footage
of grown men getting hit in the private
parts the MCU movies for all their
big-budget set pieces aren't immune to
that simple joy getting included on the
blooper reel should I do you testicles
[Music]
in the 80s and 90s Jeff Goldblum brought
a disarming charm and off-center
sensibility to his roles and otherwise
straightforward movies like Jurassic
Park and Independence Day in doing so he
made them much better than it would have
otherwise been without him it makes
sense then that when director Taika
Waititi took the Thor movies in a cosmic
and comedic direction with thor ragnarok
he brought Goldblum in for a role
Goldblum plays the Grand Master the most
hedonistic of all the elders of the
universe the actor brings his trademark
looseness and an almost jazz like
approach to the movie which is
noticeable even when he's goofing off
between takes
[Music]
Wow
take it away pores and wardrobe is about
as eye-catching as the lightning that
often accompanies the character in
addition to Chris Hemsworth's own
indisputable good looks or usually rocks
a tight metal shirt red pants and one
undeniably great faith but while the
accessory might be stylish it can be
pretty temperamental on the set of
Thor's a common world Hemsworth tries
his best to act but he has trouble due
to an unpredictable co-star is Kate
[Music]
[Applause]
haha science fiction films and superhero
movies are full of mythology backstory
and their own sets of rules Iron Man 3
is a sci-fi film as well as the
superhero movies and it's got a lot of
specific words and jargon it's actors
need to clearly and slowly deliver so
the action around them makes sense it's
a delicate balance to nail the
terminology that's been part of a comic
or cinematic universe for years so it
satisfies both hardcore and new fans
alike
that's why Marvel minutes filmmakers
hire top-notch talent to deliver the
written lines actors like Robert Downey
jr. have a training skill and talent
necessary to say all the technical talk
in a believable way still sometimes it's
hard to get those words out because even
for an actor of Downey's caliber there's
a lot to remember in Iron Man 3 Tony
Stark has to recall his various super
suits there are a lot of them and in
this blooper Downey jr. needs the
assistance of the heart breaker armor to
help out the armor whose name escapes
him
heartbreaker will you help what's your
name mr. snapper
overlap for the various super heroic
characters life Panther came out of
nowhere to introduce many fantastic
characters to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it also had the added benefit
of making huge stars out of the actors
and actresses who portrayed that
Chadwick Boseman had attained some fame
after playing Jackie Robinson and James
Brown and 42 and get on up respectively
koala Peeta Nyong'o achieved her
breakthrough with 12 years of slave now
they're a listers thanks to their roles
at the top of the cast of the superhero
action blockbuster Danai gurira
established a big-screen career for
herself beyond her role as the katana
wielding was shown on the walking dead
but in this blooper she's quickly and
effectively upstaged by yet another
breakout MCU star
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorites
topper coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
thank you for putting that together
looper really well edited you can really
feel the bloopers it really breathe in
this format this is the way all bloopers
are meant to be seen
yes described telling us what we're
gonna see really setting up every almost
every moment that was gonna happen in
the blooper then five seconds sometimes
less just a little nugget just to give
us a taste to give us an inkling for
what might have been funny about this I
mean with the prop comedy stuff that's
something that I've always thought was
impressive about what these superheroes
have to do when I was at screen junkies
recently they had Mildura Mule near no
no no mummy they might win the hammer
and picking it up it was so light looks
that way we cap shield too and it just
dawned on me of just how good of an
actor you have to be in order to do
something like that because you'll feel
silly
you'll feel dummy I mean you're looking
at that you're in the outfits and
everything's gonna get updated in
post-production with the right lighting
and the symmetry of the angles and all
the visual effects but when you're
holding those prospects I'm only imagine
just how stupid you might initially feel
doing that and you really got to sell
that and I don't feel like there's so
many superhero movies now that we don't
really take the time to just appreciate
how well these guys do it selling these
things that just can feel kind of dumb
when you're not aware of you know just
the fact that there's a camera rolling
on you oh yeah well a lot of those
weapons are made of foam so yeah they're
really easy to warp or bend or ya break
like you saw with my own ears you know
hammered part just coming and clean off
the handle I always find the physical
stuff kind of funny too because in these
movies you know it like everybody's got
to fight each other and stuff like that
my always wondering those hero shots how
many stray nut punch
is coming out you know because these
suits also have to be pretty
constrictive too so I can't imagine that
that's the most comfortable position to
be in especially when somebody like gets
you with a stray staph or hammer or
whatever yeah it's true you know people
say like oh it's kind of surprising how
goofy some of these actors really are
especially the more serious ones like to
me I don't really ever see any of
chadwick boseman goofy side like an
interviews or anything like that and he
plays a pretty straightforward character
who doesn't really behave all that silly
I mean I feel like Chris Evans we all
know that because of the fact of how he
had a lot of comedic roles prior to
Captain America now picture that but
every we know it can be funny and
everything even though Captain America
is a pretty serious dude for the most
part but people like Benedict
Cumberbatch that doesn't surprise me
especially British actors I feel like
people we tend to be surprised but the
very serious British actors because of
how talented they are with the dramatic
weight they bring to rolls but usually
they're very silly people like the
British people especially tend to be
very goofy allow her to roll oh yeah
when I got imagine that for these films
especially with as much longevity and as
much crossover as there is there's got
to be a family vibe that sort of
cultivation like I was actually kind of
surprised to see all those different
people dancing on the set of Doctor
Strange like even Mads Mikkelsen was
goofing around in there at one point but
I think my very very favorite ones out
of these and I these are the ones that
make me wish these videos could breathe
more is the ones where you just have
like a bunch of different takes of a
riff of some kind like the Stan Lee
cameo him just coming up with funny
things to say or like with the Captain
America PSA is like all the different
things he must have had to do for that
that one out of all of them was probably
one of the few that really made me laugh
even for how brief its presented here
because most of these clips just make me
go okay well I want to pull out the DVD
and see what these guys are actually
like but the whole thing about you know
like a hot lunch really tickled me in
this I love watching bloopers awhile
especially for comedy shows I actually
love to watch like Oh season four
blooper reel of friends and when I watch
those they make me laugh but they have
to be in compilation format but I'm
surprised we didn't get any of it he
is Tom Holland like there's Tom Holland
seems like he's the loosest oneness and
all workers have Brad like a little bit
of Paul Rudd of course but maybe the
videos intention was to show you the
guys who are more serious being a little
more goofy but yeah people like Tom
Holland or Chris Pratt these dudes who
are just so funny and interviews
naturally I'm surprised didn't get any
of those guys in this compilation yeah
well I feel like they'll the Tom Holland
bloopers would just be him spoiling
things about the MC and then Kevin Feige
having to tackle him
but I really did like seeing the Trevor
Slattery ones too I don't think any of
those were used in the movie were they
anyway this was a fun little thing to
dissect I always loved the footage of
these guys this was great Thank You
looper for putting this together hey
guys watch do yourselves a favor and
subscribe a looper it'll make your day a
whole lot better might make my day
better too and if you've never heard of
them tell them the real rejects sent you
I'd love to work with these guys one day
if they let me McHale thanks so much for
requesting this man when we spoke
recently you said you were satisfied
overall pretty happy with the way Game
of Thrones ended that sentence in itself
is a blooper how can anyone be satisfied
with it it's not divisive it's
objectively a bad series finale I feel
like I should just say I respect your
subjective opinion I truthfully don't as
a matter of fact you've lost a lot of
street cred with me now you have to
increase your pledge to make up for this
silly silly statement that you make yeah
you know jump up there and another 20 in
under $50 wherever you think is fair
really I want you to really think about
what you've said in what you've done
here any time you seem a little dumb to
me that's another dollar on the patreon
oh don't forget that in all seriousness
if you end up increasing your pledge
because of this sarcastic comment you
really don't have to even tell us we
will see it in the notifications and we
don't have to talk about it any further
guys subscribe take care